[Music]
all right he was the FBI agent at the
very heart of the deep state and as I
have been telling you now for a long
time the biggest corruption abuse of
power scandals sadly in our history now
in 2016 he was the lead investigator in
the Clinton's server probe he played a
lead role in writing Hillary Clinton's
exoneration of course before the
investigation before ultimately
conducting her investigation months
later despite what we now have which is
incontrovertible evidence that Hillary
Clinton was guilty of numerous serious
felonies and crimes he then immediately
transitioned to the Trump Russia
witch-hunt left wing talking point all
the while he has expressed a massive
bias in favor of Hillary Clinton who he
was supposed to be investigating and an
extraordinary extreme hatred animus
against Donald Trump to his FBI
colleague mistress Lisa page wall by the
way on official FBI phones used to
conduct official FBI business now
tomorrow Lisa page well she said to
testify like she was Wednesday before a
closed-door session in Congress we'll
see but today for the very first time in
a public setting
yes Peter struck was now forced to begin
to answer for his prejudice his bigoted
the point of view before he did an
investigation including by the way texts
and statements like these take a look
you want me to read this yes please yes
sir OMG he's an idiot
hi how was Trump other than a douche
Melania Trump is a disaster I have no
idea how destabilizing his presidency
would be and I'll preface it by saying
this for context miss page said not ever
going to become president right right no
no he's not we'll stop it repeat that
again no no he's not we'll stop it
I want to believe the path you threw out
for consideration in Andy's office that
there's no way he gets elected but I'm
afraid we can't take that risk it's like
an insurance policy in the unlikely
event you die before you're 40 what the
f happened to our country lease okay
read it again that way aye sir did you
not was I'm not here you just want to
you need to repeat it please okay sir
sure happy to indulge you I can't pull
away what the f happened to our country
lease what arrogance what narcissism
we'll stop it an insurance policy
now get this despite everything you just
heard Peter struck actually wants you to
dispense of all the common sense that
God gave you and he wants you to spend
all logic that you have all rationale
and believe in this fantasy that his
actions were not abusively biased and
frankly in my view corrupt watch this
let me be clear
unequivocally and under oath not once in
my 26 years of defending our nation did
my personal opinions impact any official
action I took this is true for the
Clinton email investigation for the
investigation into Russian interference
and for every other investigation I've
worked on it is not who I am and it is
not something I would ever do period I
understand that my sworn testimony will
not be enough for some people after all
Americans are skeptical of anything
coming out of Washington but the fact is
after months of investigations there's
simply no evidence of bias in my
professional actions I'd like to know
how many lawyers worked on that whole
show that you just saw what you just
heard is a national scandal it is a
disgrace remember it was him struck who
called the president an idiot abysmal
and his girlfriend Lisa page called him
loathsome and awful and struck said
Hillary Clinton should win the 2016
election 100 million to zero and Donald
Trump is bigoted an enormous bleep he's
a disaster he's a bleeping idiot his
presidency is bleeping terrifying this
is just a small sample by the way what
are hundreds of anti-trump texts now
congressman trey Gowdy he will be
joining us tonight in just a few minutes
he called out this cancerous prejudice
and discrimination
take a look agent Scott despite the
plain language of his texts and emails
despite the Inspector General's report
and despite common sense doesn't think
he was biased
he thinks calling someone destabilizing
for the country isn't bias
he thinks promising to protect the
country from someone he hasn't even
begun to investigate isn't bias he has a
different set of rules for others that
he's investigating agents truck thinks
saying someone he is allegedly
investigating should be elected
president 100 million to zero before he
ever interviews he doesn't think that's
bias agents truck thinks pronouncing
someone innocent before bothering to
interview more than 30 different
witnesses isn't bias if we don't get
this right we will lose this country and
of course Peter Struck's animus is
hatred towards Donald Trump it didn't
stop with just the President himself no
it also extended to Trump boaters you
know we the people all of us that are
irredeemable deplorable 'he's you know
we Americans that actually believe in
God and our Bibles and our religion and
believe in the Second Amendment take a
look at this let's just guys a text that
hits home for me
on August 26 2016 you texted Ms page
quote just went to a Southern Virginia
Walmart I could smell the Trump support
and smell is in capital letters all
capital letters
what does Trump support smell like mr.
structor
sir that's an expression of speech I
clearly wasn't smelling one thing or the
other what I was commenting on is living
in Northern Virginia what does that mean
what I what I meant by that was living
in Northern Virginia having travel in
the hundred and hundred fifty miles
south within the same state I was struck
by the extraordinary difference in the
expression of political opinion and
belief amongst the community there and
you describe that as smell in capital
letters sir that was a choice of the
quick choice of words in it sorry so
earlier
okay so earlier you had texted Ms page
on that another part of Virginia Loudoun
County which is I think in Northern
Virginia is quote still ignorant
hillbillies
end quote is that what you meant no sir
not at all then you think there are
Trump supporters to be ignorant
Hillbillies not at all
smelly Hillbillies to like Walmart now
you follow that exchange once again
Peter struck asked all of us the
American people to suspend logic and
believe he didn't really say what he was
called texting watch one more
unbelievable
insane denial you were both rooting for
Hillary Clinton to win and you both
detest it Donald Trump did you not I
think that's fair say and in fact as
we've learned you apparently found
Donald Trump supporters detestable -
like those around Loudoun virginia's
we've already heard whom you called
ignorant blanks i'm not going to say
that here and that you had visited a
southern virginia walmart and could
smell the Trump support don't you think
that the American people when they're
paying your salaries when they're paying
for a fair and unbiased investigation by
none other than the FBI deserved a whole
lot better than what those comments I
just referred to reflect congressman two
things one I absolutely regret the
appearance of some of those texts and
wish I would have said or phrased or not
said at all some of the things I did too
I take I disagree completely with your
attribution of my views of Trump
supporters I never said that I expressed
no such thing now no intelligent
American would believe that denial with
more verbal gymnastics than we actually
saw I never thought we could top this
former President Bill Clinton remember
it all depends what is is now we were
alone but I never really thought we're
alone in order to believe these bizarre
explanations from this verbal
contortionist you would literally have
to suspend all sense of fact and fiction
and of course Peter struck well he does
think that the smelly irredeemable the
horrible Trump supporters of Walmart the
hillbillies like us that believe in God
and guns and Bibles and religion we
don't measure up
he thinks yeah I guess we're pretty dumb
and he could just do whatever he wants I
have some bad news for Peter he's not
the infallible super Patriot that he
clearly is convinced himself he is he
lies to our face and in the end he's not
going to get away with it in other words
he's not above the law because the
American people saw these lies today we
know a cover-up when we see one by the
way so did congressman Louie Gohmert
take a look at this tense exchange and
you have come in here and said I had no
bias and you do it with a straight face
and I watched you in them in the private
testimony you gave and I told some of
the other guys he is really good he's
lying he knows we know he's lying and he
could probably pass polygraph know the
disgrace mystery what this man has done
gentleman from Texas will suspend for a
moment is the disgrace and it won't be
recaptured anytime soon because of the
damage you've done to the justice system
and I've talked to FBI agents around the
country you've embarrassed them you've
embarrassed yourself and I can't help
but wonder when I see you looking there
with a little smirk how many times did
you look so innocent into your wife's
eyes and lied to her about mr. chairman
it is clear it is obvious to every
American with common sense Peter struck
definitely has an unfaithful
relationship with the truth and without
a doubt this is the greatest case of
cognitive dissonance that I've ever seen
in my life he's out of touch with
reality he thinks only he knows what's
right for America it couldn't be more
obvious the poster child of what we now
know is a deep state thinking he knew
better and knows better than we
smelly Trump supporters but predictably
in order to deflect he used an
all-too-common tack
the left launched into some attack into
some of the quote extreme folks on TV
and I have a response just like yours
truly take a look
understand why people might think that
particularly based on the
misrepresentations of extreme folks in
the media conspiracy theorists folks in
this body and elsewhere and that's why
I'm glad to be here today publicly why
I'm glad to hear that people are calling
for the release of my private interview
so that people can judge for themselves
Who I am what I said and the facts and
that's something that's being spun or
misrepresented and some ten o'clock
talk-show or other place if you don't
like the reporting and the truth and the
investigations I have an invitation to
mr. arrogant one and by the way you can
bring your girlfriend Lisa page with you
we can do it right to my face and all
even all for you Peter what I offered
your boss Jim three hours of radio on
five hundred and seventy of the best
radio stations in America and right here
thanks to our loyal viewers the number
one show on all of cable news I'll give
you a full hour I'll tell you what I'll
give you two full hours we run in two
days in a row a two-day extravaganza if
your track record is so impeccable and
you really haven't done anything wrong
you're welcome two hours and three on
radio come and defend yourself I'm not
going to hold my breath and believe it
or not in addition to strux
obvious case she actually confirmed a
very important piece of information
about the deep state this is something
we have been telling you about for
months as struck admitted Christopher
Steele's dirty dossier was in fact
supplied to the FBI by Bruce or remember
or was the high-ranking Justice
Department official during the Obama
administration he was married to Nellie
or she worked for fusion GPS who were
closely yes with the foreign national
Christopher Steele who sold us Russian
lies to influence the election what's
this you said you did not personally
receive documents from mr. Oher but the
FBI did is that correct and you also
said the FBI got documents from a
different source in mid-september
different source than whom different
source from mr. Orr it was not mr. Orr
who provided the initial documents that
I became aware of in mid-september mr.
Orr did not hand you the dossier that's
me
or didn't hand me anything mr. oil
provided information to the FBI that
included material that is what
everybody's calling the dossier since
again mr. oil provided what he provided
some elements of reporting that my
understanding is originated from mr.
steel so Bruce or did give the FBI
information relative to the dossier yes
bought and paid for foreign national put
together Russian lies to influence the
election a perfect example of the deep
state working together to use a piece of
what Clinton paid for the Russian lives
yeah all to impact an influence an
election a presidential election this is
a massive abuse of power scandal
everything we have been saying is right
we don't have a lot more on this all
throughout the show but first I want to
end our monologue tonight with a message
directly to Peter struck just so you
know I love law enforcement Peter my mom
worked as a prison guard
for about 25 years of her life she
worked more 16-hour shifts than I could
ever add up a recall my father a family
court officer many relatives have worked
in law enforcement including the NYPD -
who made it to the tippy-top that worked
for that organization that I have so
much respect for the FBI they were
revered in my family and today you told
the American people not to believe your
own words they're clear meaning you
tried to cover up your bias
you took no ownership of your terrible
and despicable actions mr. struck you
are not the 99.9% of law enforcement in
this country that serve and protect us
nor was your girlfriend Lisa nor was
your boss Jim or deputy FBI director
McKay what you are is a partisan
political hack and you abuse the trust
and the power that we the smelly people
of the United States that like Walmart
gave to you the people that work hard
every single day contribute to the
society make it better
by the rules pay their taxes use their
salary obey the laws get taxed into
oblivion by corrupt government the
people who struggle to make ends meet
the ones that you have shown nothing but
contempt and hatred for and the ones you
think you're superior to and if your
chosen candidate your beloved Hillary at
one none of this corruption would have
come to light
now the deep state your days are
numbered and we smelly Trump supporters
and I'm one I'm an irredeemable
deplorable we will not rest and all of
your deep state colleagues until they
are held accountable for what you've
done here